critics love it audiences love it heck
everybody loves it but there are still a
few John Wick moments I have fans
banging for blood warnings spoilers
ahead for John Wick chapter 4.
John Wick chapter four of the stakes
early on by killing off a fan favorite
recurring character Sharon the cool
collected concierge of the New York
Continental how good to see you again so
soon Mr Wick what makes this moment even
more shocking is the fact that Sharon is
coldly executed in retaliation for a
problem that is entirely outside of his
control he essentially dies to make sure
we understand our new villain the
Marquee vonson de gromance is a really
bad dude after years of faithful service
in the name of the high table Sharon
goes out his collateral damage and it's
all because Winston doesn't hit John
Wick with a fatal shot at the end of the
last movie it's harsh to say the least
this death hits especially hard as John
Wick chapter 4 landed in theaters right
on the heels of Lance reddick's sudden
death at the age of 60. this adds an
unfortunate to soon Cloud over the story
beat as with many of reddick's best
roles the actor brings a calm and
clear-eyed gravatars to Sharon that
cements the Continental at an
authoritative edifice of power and
meaning he also plays fantastically off
the expressive of ride tones of Ian
mcshane's performance it's a tremendous
shame that John Wick chapter 4 will be
his last appearance as the character
radica been set to reprise a role in the
franchise's ballerina spin-off movie
the first two sequels to John Wick
basically begin in media rare if you're
not familiar this is story speak for
mid-fight scene these action-packed
features pick up the moment the prior
movie leaves off John Wick chapter 4 by
contrast starts remarkably slow and it
takes a movie a ponderous half hour to
set the table for the first big fight
scene at the Osaka Continental relative
to the quick Pace that's made the
franchise successful so far this is a
bold gamble for the fourth movie to take
just have fun out there it's Bolder
still because it requires the audience
of a better than cursory recall of the
John Wick timeline thus far as some fans
have pointed out it's actually kind of
hard to recall the details of the WIC vs
archaic plot mechanics even for devoted
fans the first three movies primarily
focus on a multi-sensory barrage of
fight scenes that just don't leave much
RAM in your mind to grasp all the
markers tattoos Clans and odd bits of
Latin and despite how long it takes to
get going John Wick chapter 4 doesn't
work too hard to explain what's going on
some viewers might have to Google who
the dude in the desert John kills in the
beginning even is to understand what's
at stake the villains of the John Wick
franchise take many shapes and forms
chapter 4 takes a path and trodden with
the Marquee its main antagonist who is
mostly frightening because of what he
represents just like John Wick himself
the high table of which the Marquis is a
senior member is more of an idea that
can't be killed than an actual group of
mortal people the Marquis cements this
by acting as a sadistic personification
of ancient forces like greed and power
John Wick chapter 4 finds a particularly
brutal way to let us know that Marquis
is more Twisted than usual The Vicious
villain subjects Mr Nobody to a horrific
test of will stabbing the Bounty Hunter
through the hand the Marquee essentially
demands that he pulls his hand out to
the knife's blade instead of pulling the
blade upwards Mr Nobody apparently
willing to do anything for a shot at the
John Wick contract complies in a
squeamish bit of realistic effects work
though it's a moment that fits perfectly
with the over-the-top John Wick style
it's more visceral and intense on the
franchise's normal fists and guns melees
prompting at least a few groans of
disgust in theaters
in general the John Wick movies rely
more on the Poetry of their action
sequences than the dramatic tension of
the narrative this approach shows the
most strain in John Wick chapter 4 which
slows down between action set pieces to
give us time to think what this means of
course is that the audience members are
a lot more likely to think wait what's
actually going on here for example Kane
and Mr Nobody followed John Wick around
the entire movie they're sort of trying
to kill him but they always manage to
let him go at no point is this more
confusing than when they interrupt his
face off with killer Harkin a ruthless
crime Lord who killed his former Mentor
you want to kill him
I want to kill him
what about you Mr Big it's unclear why
either mercenary is waiting so long to
kill John Wick or why Jon himself is
acting so coy about attacking killer in
truth the whole scene really just seems
like a thin excuse for him to end up
with the famous dead man's hand of Aces
and AIDS during a poker game it also
contains one of the most confusing came
related moments despite being blind he
can tell exactly what his hand is Star
Wars fans might at least enjoy this
unintentional callback to Rogue one in
which actor Donnie Yen also plays a
blind character who can still sort of
see but everyone else will be more than
a little last
perhaps fantastic acknowledgment that
the audience might be getting somewhat
desensitized to human on human violence
after four movies John Wick chapter 4
throws in a very different sort of heart
skipping moments late in his runtime
this Scene goes back to the first
movie's potent well by placing a dog in
Jeopardy although this time it's a
thankfully brief moment of canine Peril
Mr nobody's Faith or companion has more
than one is over by the time he gets
rudely tossed into a windshield but the
Marquis top henchman Chidi despite the
fact that he all but shatters the glass
and bounces into the street the dog gets
right back up and Barks to let us know
he's okay it's a sudden shock delivered
drawing an otherwise severely
choreographed scene set aside paris's
Arc de Triumph and it hits hard some
fans perhaps still scarred from the
first movie have even taken to platforms
like Reddit to make sure the dog lives
before they actually see the movie
money makes the world go round and
that's especially true in the John Wick
Universe how do we know this by the
that's as a bounty on John Wick grows
hundreds upon hundreds of people decide
that the price has suddenly right to
take him on themselves even though the
many previous attempts on the life of
Baba Yaga have failed yet there are
still exceptions to this rule for most
of John Wick chapter four it seems like
Mr Nobody is a rare character to realize
this he seems content to Simply track
Jon from place to place and try to build
the Marquee for a finders fee but late
in the game we learned that even Mr
Nobody Has a price 40 million dollars
after this he goes all out in an effort
to bag John this happens after he gets
the drop on the unkillable protagonist
multiple times sadly Mr Nobody loses a
fair amount of intrigue when we realize
that he's just like people who only
played a lottery when it gets over one
billion dollars when he changes his mind
again after John saves his dog's life it
endears him to us but it doesn't make
his character any more coherent
ready John
yeah even before the release of John
Wick chapter 4 fans pointed out that his
169 minute run time is seriously lengthy
this is a serious departure for the
franchise the first three movies in the
series endeared themselves to fans in
part by being Sprints instead of
marathons even the biggest John Wick fan
might feel like the fourth installment
needs to be shorter it doesn't help that
this feels like part of a pernicious
Trend in modern Cinema all kinds of
recent movies seem to be pushing three
hours these days and the John Wick
formula doesn't lend itself too well to
a bloated runtime the movie's length
really puts a strain on the scenes
between action sequences which mostly
consists of characters explaining made
up high table rules that are kinda hard
to follow besides he wants to miss a
killer action scene because their
bladder just can't take it give us an
intermission next time
yes you'd better believe it John Wick
dies at the end the same John Wick we've
watched kill thousands of people in a
few days over the course of the first
three movies the same John Wick who
easily survived getting hit by four cars
and falling down 500 concrete steps in
conquerable merciless Baba Yaga whose
name is in the title of every movie our
protagonist's death in what might be the
final chapter of the main franchise has
fans shocked and divided some feel like
it undermines the whole story While
others are hoping it's a total fake out
after so much violence and death it
really does feel like John Wick's
defining character trait as his ability
to survive in spite of impossible odds
in a way he exists more as a force of
nature than a man it's wildly satisfying
that his actions have came become free
of the high table and allow Winston to
get the Continental restored but for
John the outcome is no different than if
it died at any of the hundreds of
earlier points in The Saga when someone
has tried to kill him with no one left
to avenge that a strange and potent kind
of Beauty in John Wick surviving for his
own sake his apparent death in contrast
seemed to support the Marquis more
nihilistic view he sees John as
essentially defined by death and
according to this movie that may be true
and it could be the final word on the
matter
John Wick chapter 4 attempts to come
full circle as Jon sits dying on the
steps of the soccer his life flashes
before his eyes and we see him with his
wife as he lingers on their brief and
lovely marriage but some fans have been
quick to point out Daisy the adorable
beagle his wife left him after her death
a dog whose murder draws him back into
the Assassin world in the first place is
nowhere to be seen yeah I'm digging on
back now we mean no offense to the
memory of Helen Wick John loved her
immensely but Daisy deserves to be in
the Montage as well John cared so much
for her that he kicked off an entire
cinematic Saga in response to her
untimely demise seeing her failed to
appear in the Montage it's kind of like
watching the Oscars not people by
leaving them out of the in memoriam
segment
John wig chapter 4 is the first film in
the John Wick franchise to feature an
after-credit scene much to the
consternation of many fans who not
expecting one left the theater early
it's disappointing from a certain angle
to see a movie franchise once confident
enough in his own appeal to excuse such
ending teasers of future events suddenly
battle to the trend it's also kind of a
big ask to make an audience I just sat
through the longest John Wick movie yet
moreover the fans who do make it all the
way might be disappointed as the scene
itself is maddeningly brief Akira
unsurprisingly his tracked Kane down to
Avenger father's death in a Public
Square she approaches a seemingly
oblivious cane and whips out a knife but
the screen cuts to Black leaving both of
their Fates unknown this is frustrating
enough on its own first John Wick
chapter 4 also disappoints
grief-stricken fans who might have hoped
that a post-credits scene would hinder
John Wick isn't really dead after all
[Music]